let's start with nurses and then move on
to Northern Ireland do you support them
striking they've got the right strike
but actually they shouldn't be striking
then if the conditions were right and
the government had been managing the
situation right they've been speaking to
them all over the summer and they would
have been trying to deal with the
circumstances that have led to this and
don't forget this isn't just a singular
issue about hey this is about the
economy as a whole because had the
government taken the labor party's
energy price freeze when we announced it
in the summer nurses would have an extra
500 quid in their bank if they hadn't
blown the economy up in the mini
statement they would have ended an extra
600 pounds that they've lost on most
people's mortgages so there's a lot of
pressures on nurses right now and
government needs to get around the table
with them to try and facilitate a way
forward and not run away from the
negotiations which can only solve this
problem do you support the strikeout I
support their right to strike I wish
that but what I can't do is say that
this strike action is right because it
shouldn't be happening because
governments shouldn't have allowed it to
happen about nurses in Northern Ireland
who can they talk to well exactly they
should be talking to the devolved
administration because it is devolved
and don't forget that one in four people
in Northern Ireland are on a waiting
list for treatment in the NHS one in
four people things have reached a really
chronic stage there is no bigger
illustration as why the evolution
Devolution and Stormont needs to get up
and running quickly so um I'm sure you
heard the Northern Ireland secretary
saying that he feels
that there shouldn't be an election at
the moment because he's listening to
people and they don't want it yet well
the problem is he keeps changing his
mind so that that creates more
instability you know instability in
Northern Ireland is the last thing you
want so Chris Heaton Harris said that
there would definitely be elections
called the Friday before last and he
didn't call them and then he changed his
mind again but I'm going to support him
in this action because we need both
parties here in Westminster to come
together to provide some kind of
stability going forward but let's not
pretend that what's happening in
Northern Ireland is separate from what's
happening in the negotiations between
the UK and the EU the protocol
negotiations are absolutely Central to
this so it really can it really uh
confounds me it surprises me and
concerns me that Chris Eaton Harris
thinks that he can leave the
negotiations to the foreign secretary
and have no contact with the foreign
secretary if it was me I would be gluing
myself to the foreign secretary and I'd
be with him every step of the way in
those negotiations being the voice of
parties in Northern Ireland and then I
would convene all parties together and
brief them continuously on progress and
listen to what they say and feed it back
in how are you going to fix the Northern
Ireland protocol if you were a Northern
Ireland well it's quite clear that the
way forward under all that in protocol
is has always been the same we need to
make sure we just made Solid progress on
data sharing and then veterinary
services and then other individual
sectors that are being affected by it
the EU put its announcements down a year
ago the UK put its its proposals 15
months ago and for large parts of it
there's total overlap these seem to be
the only negotiations that are failing
because everybody seems to agree on the
core things and yet there's such
dysfunction in that relationship they
can't get it over the line maristovich
the EU negotiator said two days ago here
in London that it could all be sorted in
three weeks if they all applied
themselves and were willing to make the
concessions necessary on both sides they
said the same thing 15 months ago so the
question is when do they start that
three-week process with the conviction
it takes to get it across the line
there's no way around this diligence
graft and state craft is needed to do
this all the things that kirstama has in
abundance all of the things this Tory
government seem to be lacking but the
Prime Minister looks to be picking a
fight with the Europeans saying that
most of European law will be scrapped by
the time we come to the next election
why why should the Europeans feel that
they want to negotiate with us over the
Northern Ireland protocol well we have
left the EU so the government is trying
to separate ourselves from all of the
legislation which which legally we have
the right to do what we don't have the
right to do incidentally we think it's
irresponsible to do that because the
burden it places on business and also
means that it makes it more difficult to
get deals with the EU because we're
going to diverge so so radically from a
lot of the the single Market regulation
but that's a separate issue the thing
that is a real barrier is the protocol
bill that's going through the House of
Lords at the moment because that
protocol bill will unilaterally the
dismiss the European Court of uh the
European Court from uh Northern Ireland
Northern Ireland does have access to the
single Market which is regulated and is
overseen by the the ecj by doing that
they break international law because
they break unilaterally the treaty we
signed with the EU if we do that there
will be consequences it might even be
that the EU withdraws the single Market
from Northern Ireland because they say
that we're no longer they're not no
longer able to enforce Brandon Lewis
said that we would break international
law if necessarily that was over
something different uh okay so yes yeah
I know Brenda Lou said that we were
going to break the law in a limited and
specific way over the internal Market
bill which yeah yeah for the internal
Market Bill incidentally he's now
Justice secretary so this is oh is he
not no no oh he's in Saxons then isn't
he
I I've made the decision that I'm not
even going to learn who the cabinet are
until after the budget because I think
the whole lot might collapse again after
the the budget so I'll learn the cabinet
if they're still in place after that
okay to me if you would about the fact
that nurses are having to use food banks
it's appalling the the Trussell trust
said this morning that one and a half
million emergency food packages have
been dispensed in recent months you know
it just shows that the government are
incapable of running our Public Services
we've got seven and a half million
people waiting for treatment uh for for
the NHS they can't run the economy they
blew a hole in the economy and they've
got a 45 billion pound Gap they're still
trying to close which which they they
did themselves that's a crisis made in
Downing Street being paid by workers
trying to fix it now but what I'm well
he's fixing their own mess and
everybody's going to pay for it nobody
was talking about cuts and austerity
before the mini budget nobody was this
is a result of Tory policy they've
broken the economy they are breaking our
Public Services uh our relationships
around the world are strained sometimes
to Breaking Point uh that our trade deal
with the US is off our trade deal with
the EU is straight is training we're not
being able to build on it because it's
dysfunctional growth in this country
tree has been stagnant and because we
have low growth we have high taxes our
economy is being badly run our public
services are being mismanaged it really
is time for a fresh start yeah there are
challenges all around the world it's not
just um the economy here in the United
Kingdom but only one country around the
world has had three prime ministers in
six months only one country in the world
has had three chancellors in six months
only one country in the world uh that's
comparable to Britain has just blown a
hole in its public finances and
unnecessarily caused a 45 billion pound
hole in its public finances by doing
unfunded tax cuts rattling the markets
and crashing the cost it costs for
government to borrow three prime
ministers in seven weeks actually
um Gavin Williamson
um where are we with him
well I think Gavin Williamson uh just
shows that Richard sunak either has very
bad judgment or he's making decisions
that aren't in the interest of the
country just simply to keep his back
benches happy what we see with the
decisions that Rishi seen us made with
his cabinet is he's put organizers and
fixes into departmental jobs not because
they're good at running departments but
because they're good at fixing problems
on their own back benches so three
former uh Chief whips are now running
government departments uh we've got
grants
it doesn't seem to be a very nice bloke
no I believe he's not but I think we all
know that now I don't need to labor the
point we've all known it I mean he I've
seen him uh sort of you know sliming his
way around Parliament and I've never
really understood why he intimidates
people you know I see him as as a sort
of you know a sort of tin pot bully you
know I have no idea why he was able to
have the influence over his party that
he did because I just assume if he tried
with me what he's been trying with other
people you know you would just see
straight through it it wouldn't happen
but it will also I look at our chief
whip
we're not supposed to talk about the
chief whip but you know we we have such
respect for for our chief whip the
relationship is is a tough relationship
it is straight down to business it's
somebody who commands respect he doesn't
bully people into respect he earns the
respect but we have a series of Chief
whips on their side that seem to resort
to to crass bullying and coercion uh at
the drop of a hat so that's why it keeps
tipping over in the House of Commons no
your opposite number tells me that lots
of MPS and members of the House of Lords
have downloaded the I'm a celebrity app
in order to vote for Matt Hancock time
and again have you no no no no no I I
want nothing to do with it um you know
I'm I'm very severely dyslexic when I
heard that Matt Hancock had used the
exclusive dyslexia for going on there I
was I was really upset by it because I
want dyslexia to be associated with
success for those of us who have
neurological neurological challenges and
we overcome them you know I think we all
acknowledge that it gives us something
positive even life because the what you
learn by overcoming challenges is a
pathway to success very often what Matt
Hancock has done is once again just
Associated dyslexia with failure and I
hate that you know I just wish that we
could get back to the point where we're
talking about the positive attributes to
some of the barriers that people have in
life Matt Hancock just seems to be
always dragging all the good things in
life down into the gutter it's good to
see you thanks very much thank you for
joining us on the program Peter Cal
thank you